on any other day the pope's appearance
in vatican city without a mask on
might have generated more headlines
but the catholic leader had set the news
agenda with his clearest pronouncement
yet
on gay relationships
in a documentary about his life which
premiered at the rome film festival
the pontiff said he thinks same-sex
couples should be allowed to have civil
unions
telling filmmakers homosexual people
have the right to be a family
they are children of god what we have to
have is a civil union law
that way they are legally covered
he added that he'd stood up for that
principle apparently referring to his
time as archbishop of buenos aires
when he endorsed some legal protections
for same-sex couples
and many will see his comments in the
documentary as a major step forward
this will make i think a significant
impact in many countries where
gay people do not have basic civic
rights and recognition
of their partnerships he's not in favor
of gay marriage
he's not in favor of opening the
institution of marriage to gay people
and he believes that gay marriage is an
impossibility he's always maintained
that
what he's saying is that everybody
whatever their sex and whatever their
relationship
have a right to have the legal support
this is a man
in the documentary called francesco the
pope is also seen encouraging two gay
men to attend church with their children
but some question whether this really
marks a fundamental shift
in a church which still opposes gay
marriage and has called homosexuality
deviant behavior i think we were a
little surprised
and it has definitely taken a long time
to get to this point
and we know that it's testament to the
hard work and the labour and the
activism
of all of the lgbt people inside and
outside of the catholic church to help
bring about this positive change
pope francis's comments are certain to
divide opinion
amongst catholics but may well engender
debate
about how the church adapts to reflect a
changing society